Es ist schon verrückt.
Der Kuipergürtel ist ganz anders als erwartet.
Wow!
Denn eigentlich wurden sort unzählige kleine
Objekte erwartet.
Aber sie sind gar nicht da!
Was ist da draußen los?
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht’s.
Herzlich willkommen!
Wenn Sonden in den Weltraum fliegen, dann
bringen sie meist wirklich sehr überraschende
bahnbrechende Erkenntnisse!
Beim Saturnmond Enceladus stieß die Raumsonde
Cassini auf Hinweise von außerirdischem Leben
oder eben jetzt New Horizons.
Die Sonde, die das weitest entfernte von Menschen
bisher aus der Nähe untersuchte Objekt genauer
unter die Lupe nahm.
Ultima Thule war nicht nur extrem seltsam
geformt, sondern hatte auch eine Eigenschaft,
die die Forschungsteam stutzig machte: Wenige
Krater, zu wenige Krater.
Denn eigentlich hätter der Himmelskörper
übersät sein müssen mit Kratern.
Denn der aktuelle Stand der Wissenschaft vermutete
im Kuipergürtel, also einem Asteroidengürtel
rund um unser Sonnensystem jenseits des Neptun
unzählige kleinere Objekte.
Und die müssten auf Objekten wie Ultima Thule
einschlagen und Spuren hinterlassen.
Aber die gibt es nicht.
Und auch auf dem Plutomond Charon fehlen diese
Spuren.
Eigentlich müssten Objekte mit einem Durchmesser
von 90 Metern bis 1,6 Kilometern auf beiden
Objekten Spuren hinterlassen haben, aber Pustekuchen.
Nichts.
Der Kuipergürtel ist einfach ganz anders
als gedacht.
Und auch anders als der Asteroidengürtel
zwischen Mars und Jupiter.
Denn der ist voller solcher Objekte, die die
Erde dazu noch ständig bedrohen.
Wir berichten ja immer wieder über drohende
Einschläge und solche die auch immer wieder
stattfinden.
Das Forschungsteam um Kelsi Singer vom Southwest
Research Institute ist baff.
Denn nach ihren Ergebnissen muss der Kuipergürtel
ganz anders entstanden sein, als der Asteroidengürtel
zwischen Mars und Jupiter, wo immer wieder
Objekte zusammenstoßen und neue Asteroiden
entstehen.
Im Kuipergürtel scheint das anders zu verlaufen.
Dort existieren wohl viel weniger dieser Objekte.
Und ads wirft auch wieder ein neues Licht
auf die These, dass es gar keinen Planet 9
geben würde, sondern er aus einem Ring aus
zehntausenden Objekten mit zusammengenommen
seiner vermuteten Masse quasi simuliert werde.
Wenn diese Ergebnisse ab stimmen, dann ist
es keines Falls klar, dass solche Asteroidenringe
immer vollgestopft mit solchen Objekten sind.
Und auch bei Planet 9 wird die existenz eines
solchen Rings stark bezweifelt.
Die jetzige Entdeckung dürfte diese Vermutung
nochmal bestärken und die Existenz von Planet
9 wahrscheinlicher machen.
Soweit draußen gäbe es damnach gar nicht
solche riesigen Materialwolken oder zumindest
sind sie anders zusammengesetzt, als bisher
vermutet.
Das könnte dann auch für die Oortsche Wolke
noch weiter draussen gelten.
Aber all das sind bloße Vermutungen, aber
sie zeigen auf jeden Fall, wie wenig wir noch
selbst über unser eigenes Sternensystem wissen.
Das Sonnensystem Spannendes Video!
Unbedingt draufklicken, anschauen und Raumzeit
Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren.
Bis dann bleibt dran.